- It's always lovely to see you.
You know Michael, I'm sure
y'all know each other.
- I know Michael, love Michael.
I know you, love you.
These are two of the greatest
singers ever in life.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- You know what's funny?
We've never sang together.
- I wouldn't even try.
- [Kelly] Oh, shut your mouth.
- [Randy] Come on! Come on!
- You know just before the
commercial break ended,
I literally, just so I could spit it out
before I have to go, I say like,
you are the greatest vocalist
on our planet I think.
- You are so nice, but
we need to sing together
at some point. I never
even put that together.
- And listen, and listen,
not to give props,
we gotta give flowers
where flowers are due,
that means props.
Kel, I'm gonna call you Yo-Kels.
- [Kelly] Cool, I'm into it.
- You were so good on the ACMs
with one of the hardest
songs to sing in life.
- Oh my god. I wanted to die.
(audience clapping)
- I'm telling you guys,
that's how great she is.
I mean...
- I was nervous.
I don't get nervous singing, okay?
But then they were like,
"hey, will you do this Dolly tribute?"
And I'm like, "oh my god,
I love her, absolutely."
So I say yes, and then they're like,
"cool, it's 'I Will Always
Love You,'" and I was like,
"I'm sorry?"
(audience laughs)
I was like, "uh, no..."
And I was like, so nervous about it.
Because it's her song,
but a lot of people know, it was popular
it was obviously "The
Bodyguard," Whitney Houston.
And so, I was so nervous.
I was so- like, literally,
I slept so well that night.
I was like, it's over!
(Randy laughs)
- You know, as we would
always say on "Idol,"
as you probably do on
"The Voice," or whatever,
you have to make a song your own.
That's the toughest one to make your own
because Whitney sang it unbelievably,
- [Kelly] I know.
I mean she made it just...
I mean, but Kelly, the greatness
of KC Yo-Kels right here,
you did it, man.
(audience claps)
- Oh my god, that means
so much coming from you.
- Dude, I'm saying it's hard.
- It was... (Kelly laughs)
- Why are we so talented?
(audience laughs)
Why? You too, I mean.
- All three of us.
Why are we gods and queens...
- Oh god, America, you
are so lucky to have us.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- God bless,
thank you for having us, America.
- [Kelly] You are welcome.
But let's talk about "Name That Tune,"
'cause this is a fun show.
I love, like, all people
that you have on there.
It's very fun.
- We got celebs this season.
We got, like, Olympians
playing against each other,
Shaggy and Kim Fields,
JoJo, the great singer,
with Kelly Osborne.
(audience claps)
I mean, it's funny, I mean,
Vernon Davis and Victor Cruz, you know,
you got the athletes you got,
- [Michael] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Michael] That's amazing.
- Frankie Muniz and, um,
Jodie Sweetin are playing.
So it's a fun kind of
thing, because, you know,
as you guys both know, you
can hum along with a song,
and I see these contestants on there,
every lyric, but they
can't think of the title.
"What's the title, wait
a minute, wait a minute."
If I hum something right now,
- Oh, I love competing! Let's do it.
(audience laughs)
(Michael laughs nervously)
- You're going down, Bublé!
- Ah, okay.
- Yeah.
- I can see it in your eyes,
you got really intense there.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- Listen, the iconic bitter note is really
what the thing's about,
you see me playing with the piano,
I can name that song in five notes,
I can name that song in four notes,
and what it is, you get clues,
and you have to listen to the-
- "Bohemian Rhapsody!"
Sorry.
(audience laughs)
Alright.
I'll stop.
- I would love it.
I love a game
- Okay, I will
give you guys a clue.
- Okay fine.
- There was a song
that was so iconic
it started it all in the musical TV genre.
- It started it all
with a musical TV genre?
- Okay, so it's a theme show?
- It's not a theme song,
but it's from a show.
- Okay. I would, I mean...
(Michael and Kelly scat)
Oh I know what it is! (Michael scats)
- [Randy] No, no, no. Listen to the clue.
- [Kelly] You just keep losing.
- [Randy] Listen to the clue.
See the clue's important.
- Okay.
- It was the crowning moment.
- "What if I told you..."
I don't know, like, "A Moment Like This"?
I'm going there.
- That's the one!
there you go!
(Kelly shrieks)
(audience applauds)
- Oh my god! Oh my god!
- You got it! You got it! You got it!
(Randy claps)
- Wait, wait!
- She not only sang it,
it's hers and she got it.
- Nobody wants to guess it, wouldn't you?
You sound like a tool.
It obviously had to be.
"A Moment Like This." Oh my gosh, really?
- There's a little nepotism in this game.
(audience laughs)
- No, no, no, no, no,
listen, listen.
- But I didn't even guess!
- But listen, people come on the show,
they can't even think of their own songs
because they're not
listening to the clues.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- That- see, but you said game shows,
so I went "Price Is Right,"
I went, like, a different
kind of a competition.
- That's a good one too,
but this was the crowning moment.
And Kels did it, you guys. Kels did it!
(audience cheers)
- Now, did I?
I feel like I cried the
entire time, and it's fine.
- Can I ask a question,
both of you, just quick,
I know you're gonna
cut me out of this, but
(Randy laughs)
I love TV themes, what is your favorite,
you and you, what is your...
if you had to pick one
television theme, wham,
what is it?
- Oh my god,
there's so many good ones
in, like, the eighties.
- [Randy] There's so many great ones, man.
- And the nineties.
- I think I know mine,
I think mine's...
- Wait, what's yours?
- Mine's "Cheers."
- [Kelly] Okay, "Everybody
Knows Your Name," yeah?
- I love that song.
- [Kelly] That's a good one.
- I like (Randy scats a tune)
(Michael and Kelly join in and scat)
- "I Dream Of Jeannie!"
- "I Dream Of Jeannie."
'Cause I like the whole bossa
vibe going on, you know?
- I like it too.
- There's so many
in my head right now, but
I think I'm, what's a...
"Milkman, the paper
boy, the evening TV..."
- Oh yeah.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "Full House!"
- Yeah, I like that song.
"Everywhere you look..."
yeah, I like that one.
- "There's a place-" I could just go,
I might just record that now.
- "Step by step,
- You should record that.
day by day by day!"
- Wait a minute, a duet tonight.
- Okay.
- Oh yeah.
Well, all three! "Come
and knock on our door!"
(audience laughs)
Honestly, I forget this is a TV show.
I'm so cozy with you guys,
I feel like I can- can I come back again?
- Yes. Same panel.
- Hey, wait a minute,
should we play poker or something?
- I love poker!
- Yeah, me too!
- I just bought a poker table
for my ranch in Montana.
- Whoa!
- Are you gonna come visit me?
- I'll come to Montana.
- It's cold as hell, but it's fun.
- Cold as hell but it's fun.
- Yeah. We're all competitive.
- Of course.
- Okay. I love it.
- [Randy] But that's what it
is, that's what it's about.
- Okay, next time we have to play a game
that we're all here for.
- Yes. Let's play a game.
- Okay, okay. Let's have
this date again, guys.
Okay. Okay.